وضمن التحركات المرتبطه بالحرب في
اوكرانيا دبلوماسيه الامريكيه تصل الى
اسيا الوسطى في محاوله لسحب جمهوريات
المنطقه من فلك روسيا والصين وزير
الخارجيه وصل الى كازاخستان في زيارته
الاولى منذ توليه منصبه وهو معتبر مسعا
امريكيا لتوسيع نفوذ واشنطن في المنطقه
ومنع روسيا من الالتفاف على العقوبات
الدوليه المفروضه
قمه جمهوريات اسيا الوسطى والولايات
المتحده او ما يطلق عليها مجموعه
والتي تضم كلا من الدوله المضيفه
كازاخستان
وتركمانستان واوزباكستان افتتح وزير
الخارجيه انطوني بنكن زيارته بالاجتماع مع
نظيره الكازخي مختار كيلوبردي في العاصمه
قبل التوجه الى القصر الرئاسي للقاء
الرئيس قاسم جومارت توكيف
[موسيقى]
اغتنم هذه الفرصه للاعراب عن تقديرنا
للدعم المستمر والثابت من الولايات
المتحده لاستقلالنا وسلامه اراضينا
وسيادتنا
من جانبه اشاد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
بعمق العلاقات بين واشنطن واستنا مشيرا
الى ان بلاده ستستمر في الدفع باتجاه
تقويه العلاقه بين الدولتين
[موسيقى]
من المهم بالطبع على المستوى الثنائي
البناء على العمل الرائع الذي انجز على
مدى اكثر من 30 عاما لتعميق وتقويه
شراكتنا واعتقد اننا في العامين الماضيين
اكدنا اهميه هذه العلاقه القويه والتي
ستزداد قوه ونحن ملتزمون بذلك